now i often say this i don't know where
i heard david foster wallace say this
but he said that the key to life is to
be unborable
that is the embodiment of this
philosophy and i when
people ask me for advice like
young students you know i don't find
this interesting i don't find this
interesting how do i find the thing i'm
passionate for
uh this would be very interesting to
explore because you kind of say that
that may not be a realizable
uh thing to do which is to be unborable
but my advice usually is life is amazing
like
you should be able to you should strive
to discover the joy
the levitation in everything
and uh the thing you get stuck on for a
longer period of time that might be the
thing you should stick to but everything
should be full of joy so that kind of
cynicism of saying uh life is uh
boring
is a thing that will prevent you from
discovering the thing
that will give you deep meaning and joy
but you're saying
being unborable
is
not actionable
for a human being so okay excellent
question deep question and and the um
you might think
because of the title of that of the book
that bert and i wrote all things shining
that i think all things are shining
[Laughter]
and uh but actually
i think it's an unachievable goal to be
unbearable i i do believe that you're
right that a lot of times when people
are bored with something it's because
they haven't tried hard enough
and i do think quite a lot of what makes
people bored with something is that they
haven't paid attention well enough
and that they haven't listened as as you
were saying
um so i i do think there's something to
that i think that's a deep insight
on the other hand
the
perfection of that insight is that
nothing
is ever anything less than joyful
and i actually think that dostoevsky and
melville both
agree but in very different ways
that
life involves a wide range
of moods
and that all of them are important
it involves grief like i think
when someone dies it's appropriate to
grieve
and it's not in the first instance
joyful
it's related to joy because it makes the
joys you feel when you feel them
more intense
but it makes them more intense by
putting you in the position of
experiencing the opposite
and it's only because
we're capable of a wide range of
passionate responses to situations
that i think the significances can be as
meaningful as they are so melville again
has this has this sort of interest i
mean
let's just say the guilt and the grief
in in the brothers karamazov alyosha
loses his mentor father zasima he's
grieving it's super important that he's
grieving he has a religious conversion
on the basis of grieving where he sees
the sort of deep sort of beauty of
everything that is but it comes through
the grief not by avoiding the grief uh
and and melville says something like
ishmael says something like he says i'm
like a catskill mountain eagle the
catskills mountains nearby he says who's
sort of flying high above the earth
going over the peaks and down into the
valleys i have these ups and these downs
but they're all invested with a kind of
significance they all happen at an
enormously high height because it's
through the mountains that i'm flying
and even when i'm down it's a way of
being up
but it's really down
it's just that it's a way of being up
because it makes the ups even upper
well i guess then the perfectionism of
that can be destructive
i mean i i tend to uh see for example
grief a loss
of love as part of love in that it's a
celebration of the richness of feelings
you had
when you had the love so it's like it's
all part of the same experience but if
you turn it into an optimization problem
where everything can be unborable then
that can in itself be destructive yeah
yeah
you